hi everybody uh from my home i'm i'm
hoping
everybody is staying safe at their house
uh because i am
at home one my hair isn't getting any
shorter
so excuse me for the appearance and if
my cat
suddenly comes walking over well we'll
excuse her and there's nothing we can do
because cats
anyway um this is the original song
these boots were made for walking and
that's just what they'll do
one of these days these boots are going
to walk all over you
i took the liberty of changing the
lyrics a bit
these micro services are made for
testing and that is just what we'll do
one of these days these tests are going
to help a lot
to you and this is exactly about that
about how to test microservices
and not only will we talk about testing
microservices
i will live code a test for
microservices
on stage and people love live coding and
i've always asked myself
why and i think the answer is it's like
uh
the arena in the the you know
the gladiators in rome um people really
want
the lion to eat the gladiator so people
really want in me and during the live
coating to you know feel
spectacularly i hope i hope it'll be
good
we'll see we have a link to the github
repo and to this presentation here
you will get it in the last slide and
and it's on youtube so you can look
whenever you want
uh feel free to uh take the github
review includes
all the code we will be seeing in this
talk
okay a little bit about me um i go back
all the way back to the 80s i'm really
old
um i did the startup thing and you know
founding a startup and being the cto and
all that
didn't really like it it was interesting
cool but didn't really like it
it seems that i i am a developer i was a
developer and
probably will be a developer till the
day i die i love testing code
uh testing the code i write it's my
passion i've been doing it since about
the year 2000 maybe a little
even a little earlier and because i love
testing
i am currently a developer relations and
an architect
a software architect at appletools what
we do is we deliver
visual testing tools so if you're a
front-end developer
and you want to test not only how your
application functions which is you know
what
things like selenium and cypress are but
also how they look like
that they look the same as they should
uh then
go see our appletools.com site and
check it out or you can contact me uh
sometimes earlier
okay so i'm not going to talk about what
our microservices but
just a baseline just so we understand
what we're talking about
there are a lot of talks about
microservices online but here are the
basics
first of all they are web apps um just
like regular you know front-end facing
web apps but they're back and facing
they only work on back-end
a micro service architecture is an
architecture where instead of one big
app
one big web app you're taking that one
big app and
making it into a lot of uh of web
small web apps and they all communicate
with each other how do they communicate
uh either via http so
if i want to i want to call something
from one web app to another i
do an http and send over json or a
graphql
uh query or put a message in a message
here the other app reads it
puts in another message etc etc the most
important thing about microservices is
that they are
independent so each microservice is a
full has its own code does not share
code with others can be deployed
separately and the most important thing
for us tested separately and that's the
most important thing
so it's compiled built and deployed
separately and that is its most big
advantage
why because if you have a large
large product with lots of teams each
team can be responsible for a set of
micro services
and they can do whatever they want there
they don't have to synchronize with
other teams because they can compile
build and deploy
their microservices independent of their
other teams
but unfortunately that comes with a
price because they're not allowed
they have to be independent they are not
allowed to share data with other
microservices
that creates a lot of complications i
don't know
about that but there are a lot of talks
about that online so
a good example is what i've i'm working
on on the other tools it's called the
apple tools visual grid
and the idea is and just a quick idea
is when we're instead of taking a
screenshot of the app like a png
what we do is we take the dom snapshot
we take the html the css
the svgs the fonts whatever
upload them to the visual grid and then
uh
recreate the page and we have lots of we
have like thousands and thousands of
browsers chrome firefox safari ie
whatever
recreate them you know those browsers
take the screenshots and then
push them to our server where they can
be diffed and checked and managed and
all that
so we can parallelize instead of taking
one screenshot we can parallelize and
take
like 10 screenshots in different browser
configurations all at the same time
how does this work our sdk instead of
taking a screenshot
takes all the dom snapshot services the
html the css the the svgs the png's etc
and puts them to our snapshot server
where they are stored in the cloud
then it posts a render job uh to the
rendering area please render the
snapshot that i just sent you
in chrome 1024 or in firefox 1024 or
1280 or whatever uh the rendering api
that is a microservice and the snapshot
server is also a microservice and they
are totally independent
uploads uh submits a job to a job queue
um and the workers each
we have workers for each browser a
chrome worker a firefox worker an ie
worker etc safari worker
takes the jobs from the job queue and
sends them over navigates to a certain
url in the headless chrome so
the worker includes both the our code
and the chrome
browser itself in headless mode that
the url is a url to the snapshot server
to get
and recreate the page the central server
generates the html that is used to
recreate the page
once we have that page in the browser we
just take a screenshot
and boom we're done the important thing
is not understanding the visual grid
it's understanding that here we have
four separate microservices and in the
case of chrome and firefox we have a lot
of instances of those microservices
and each one is compiled built and
deployed
and tested independently of one another
and the most important thing for us
is that they are tested independently
and that they aren't huge
each one of these microservices
is doing one task in one task only so
they're not
huge in terms of amount of code
okay we've understood microservices
let's talk about tests
why do we write tests and we have two
answers for that one is
because we have to and because we don't
like doing manual testing so every time
we change something we don't want to
manually test it
but why do we test at all and and my
answer is and i'm sorry for people who
saw my
uh talk at reactivecon this is like a
very quick summary of that
um my my my
my point of view on on why is
i call it echo programmable what is echo
programmaphobia it is
fear of my code okay i know
that i fear my code my own the code that
i write i
fear it and why do i fear it well
when we add code we always think of it
as a lego thing that you just add but we
all know the reality the reality is once
we add code
everything breaks or a lot of stuff
breaks or sometimes doesn't break at all
but we don't know so every time we add
some code to our application
we fear adding that code removing code
supposed to be the easiest thing
possible and nobody is using that css
rule right
we've we've seen that a lot but we all
know what happens
a lot of times when we remove code yes
it was used for something
and refactoring we all want to refactor
but we're
really really frightened because we know
how the refactoring starts
but we never know how it ends just like
the sporty kitty
it knew it knew how it starts it didn't
know how it ends
so and it doesn't really matter if if
our code is
really really nice or it's really really
ugly and spaghetti
we fear changing it it doesn't really
matter because adding removing or
refactoring code
is a change and that change breaks stuff
we can't avoid it unless we're total
geniuses and nobody is
and testing is what abolishes stops echo
programmer phobia it's like the pill
that you take to remove that fear of
your own code
because you write your tests okay
add your code run your tests they run
perfect we're good we can deploy they
don't run
we fix the bug and then deploy
okay so um we talked about microservices
we talked about testing let's talk let's
let's do stuff
let's live code a microservice and i i
chose a really simple microservice
uh i mentor some some people
uh on my on my own spare time some
junior developers
and we're building this building uh
application
where you have tenants of the building
you know people
live there and they have to pay rent and
all that stuff
so it's the micro service i'm talking
about it very simple it
has a crud interface to attendance
database we're using postgres
postgres and you can add stuff it has an
api
a rest api where you can add a tenant
delete a tenant
update a tenant and list all things
classic
crud okay we're gonna live a test not
the micro service itself the microsoft
itself is written but let's look look at
it
where are we okay this is the code
and it's as i said it's in the github
repo you have you have the link and
we'll put it in the comments later
uh i like to separate my source and my
tests
some people like them together just a
matter of opinion
let's start with the docker file because
a microservice is usually
really served by docker i don't want to
get into docker it's a whole
thing but in the end what is important
is that the entry point of the
application is run microservices are
made for testing okay so it's this one
okay okay so let's look at the app
oh sorry no it's this one it's this one
let's look at the main this is the main
this is what is running
what it does is it calls create app
to create an app if it was if i was
using express
then i it would be creating an express
app
but i'm using fastify because i
festifies much better
and supports promises natively so please
stop using express use fastify um
so create app will create that app it's
not yet listening on a port it's
just creating that app and we'll talk
later about why we're doing that
then we're taking the port okay and
listening on it
but notice two things when we're
creating the app we're sending it the
parameters
the parameters in a regular microservice
is mostly
sent via environment variables there are
other ways but mostly
so what this this code does it just
takes the environment variables
and sends them to create app and if you
think of create app create app
is devoid of any thought about
environment variables or whatever and
that is very important for testing
we'll talk about that later and then we
listen and notice that we listen
not in the create app why why why am i
going on about that creator because that
create app
that is what we mostly test we don't
want to
uh run a process or run a docker
instance to to to test it because that's
heavy and that's very difficult to debug
what we want is just to get the app you
know listen on it
and boom we have a running app so
this is we won't be we mostly won't be
testing
this function what we will be testing is
the create app
create app is an src and it's our main
entry point
and it's getting the database connection
string as we said
earlier when it's running in a micro in
a docker container it will
get it from the environment variable
because here
because this right but because
but if we want to send another database
connection stream that's fine
we create a fastify application we
connect to the database
okay and then we define routes
slash returns a health check api tenants
gets the list of tenants etc etc
i want to talk about that retry because
again that's important for testability
why do we need to retry a connection to
database in production
that database is always there true
but not in the tests in the test
sometimes the application runs
quicker than the the database so that
we're when we're running the test and
running
both of them that have database the app
isn't ready the app is ready
and it wants to connect but the database
isn't ready so we
try another example of where things have
to be testable we change
the application slightly to be testable
okay oh and where i'm using the
wonderful p
retry from cinderella sorrows and i hope
i'm
saying it correctly okay so we're
listing
we're using uh a simple query okay
first name last name from tenants and
we're transforming it into first name in
in
in like in camel case
using a steel road to objects or
returning an array of tenants
uh let's talk about adding a tenant we
uh we're posting when we're posting a
tenant with an id
then we insert it into the database
uh and and basically that's the app it's
not
that difficult okay and we connected the
database we saw the code it's just
postgres code i'm using the the regular
postgres client
but notice something else i'm exporting
the database schema
why am i exporting the database schema
if i'm not even creating the database
it's the dba's
work to create that table right in the
database
and again the answer is testability in
the test i need to create the database
schema
that table i don't want it to be in the
test code i want it to be close to the
production code
so i put it here even though it's not
really necessary so another testability
issue
notice the interesting thing this has
nothing to do with microservices or
testing
i'm using the new capability of nodejs
to use import and export uh native
import export i'm not transpiling
anything this is pure javascript
and it's a replacement for common js for
require in node.js
i'm a huge fan of node es modules uh
did a talk about that so i decided to
convert from common js to node
es modules i wanted to convert this
application and it's working
okay um so that is the app
um very very simple app notice things
the testability one i'm separating
i'm separating the running and the
getting of the environment variables and
the listening
from the main core of the app two
i'm retrying the connected database
because in tests i don't know which is
going on which goes up first
and three i'm exporting the videos
okay so let's see if i showed everything
the rest api needs some communication
using sql the reach i've connected to
the database the
scanner and separation of app and
running app
and configuration has nv variable and
those three are
testing related yay i've shown
everything
so what will we be rewriting we will be
writing unit tests
integration tests and endless those are
the types of tests we'd be writing
but no we won't be writing unit tests
there are tons of information about
writing unit tests
everybody when they start talking about
unit tests they start with unit tests
like add
you know everybody just takes a unit a
function like ad
and tests it for all the various use
cases
i don't want to talk about that we'll
talk about how much unit tests we need
and everything in the end but let's
let's ignore that for now
because the most important thing is
integration does
how do integration just work first of
all we run the server
our server our web app okay then we run
all the services it depends on the
database
the message queue whatever and how will
we do that we will be using docker
compose
docker compose can run a lot of docker
containers so if i'm using redis and
postgres and a message queue and
everything
i can put them in one docker compose
file and just run that
boom this is wonderful it changed the
whole way we think of
integration tests in node.js in other
languages
and now we've done the setup
now for each test what we do we do we do
an http call to this the web app okay
to test let's say i want to test add
tenants
so http for ad and then i http for lists
to check that the list of tenants has
added that tenant
and check that it works correctly in the
end we tear down
the server and the docker containers and
all that
that's basically how integration tests
work
let's see an example okay
let's see an example
endless all my incline tests are here
[Music]
okay um there we go
so first of all i use uh um a library i
built
back in the days called the um docker
composed mocha
it has nothing to do with mocha but
anyway a bad name
uh which what it does is it gets a
the name of a docker compose file in
this case
this docker compose file which has just
one container in it the postgres
container
okay and the various environment
variables that the postgres container
needs
and runs it and in the before
runs the docker container and the after
kills the docker containers this is very
cool
uh not only that it has this cool effect
where
in the next time you run it maybe there
are like rogue
containers from from previous runs so it
kills them also
anyway that's that's what i run oh
there's a cat
uh first of all uh in the before i
prepare the database
which is create schema and in the before
each i reset the database which is clean
all the rows from the tenants
table we'll see that in a second and
then in the before i set up the app
what does setup app mean uh come on
click
there we go setup app uh
i get the uh the address of postgres
from
docker compose it's not as specific
every time
the docker compose tool runs i get a
separate address
it's not a specific address
why because i may have multiple tests
running and i don't want them like
interfering with one another so every
port is random
then i create the app and give it the
connection string it needs
for uh for postgres see i've just
created the app
just using a function call and then i
listen on what port
port 0 what is port 0 it means get me
for random port
i don't care what it is again all tests
microservice tests
should use random ports because if you
want to run them in parallel and you
will want to run them in parallel at a
certain time
you don't want them interfering with one
another
so that's the setup and then let's look
at the test uh let's see
it should return that after it is added
this is a test of test
adding a tenant so we you know create a
tenant with a with a random id
using uuid first name built-in
[Music]
and then we add a tenant i'm using my
nice library http commands
which is a very very very very earlier
it is very small wrapper above node
fetch
[Music]
and what it does is in this case it uses
this url
fetches a json and posts
this json to it so this will basically
add a tenant
notice the base url here the base url
[Music]
i i get the address from the app
instance i created earlier app
instance.server.masters.port
so this is the port that was created
randomly
by the setup app if you remember our app
port
okay and then i just you know post it
that adds a tenant and then have to
check
i fetch the list of tenants and
boom i check that it's equal to um
let's run just this test it dot only
and i do npm run test mocha i don't want
to run all the tests
see it's running the docker compose and
boom
we're passing great
okay now we've shown the example
let's live code an integration test so
this is the part with the line
okay to delete the user
okay this is this is what i'm going to
test how do we delete a user first
of all let's see how much time do i have
okay first of all i
create three users okay
um okay and then after a while i'll
write the code in a sec i list the users
uh not users sorry you should delete the
donut oops
sorry create three cannons
list the tenants and then check
the only tenants are the last ones or
oh wait i didn't really create the three
then delete the first hand
and check whether the only tenants are
the last ones
perfect but notice we
have create we have add and we have list
and it's really really not nice that i
have to write this whole thing
so let's do some refactoring because
visual studio code is
really cool about this so we take all
this
we command dot it and i say extract the
function
boom and we'll call it add tenant
yay now the base url here is a function
so i'm gonna you know munch it a little
bit
there we go and i have that here
and let's do the same for list
[Music]
and we'll extract the function list
tenant remember your
your test code is almost as important as
your production code keep it
nice and clean
[Music]
enough url and here we'll pass in
by the way why why is base url a
function um
well what happened here oh sorry why is
base url a function
because i don't know beforehand what
the um what the port is
so i can only calculate it lazily it can
be a const address
i can only calculate it lazily okay
let's you know let's do it like
stuff because really
you really like nice code okay
update the user
okay wait
i'll paste you around
okay let's stands
there we go all as long as we're here
links to the update
also i extract
function update
[Music]
i will do the thingy
refactoring
wow the code is much nicer look at it i
can even remove the comments i i'm not a
huge oh
we didn't do an ad here and then
base url and then
i'm not a huge fan
[Music]
nice okay
it has actually when you're testing
right clean code
that is very very important uh so let's
create three tenants
so let's first of all create dependents
const tenants
equals
me as an example
[Music]
and my wife
with a bomb
[Music]
and a good friend of mine who is
very much into microservice testing he's
also a
uh consultant so if you want to if
you're a
company wants to go into dive deep into
microservices testing you need to
consult on that
go talk to him he's wonderful and we
have like similar views on
microservice testings okay so we have
the tenants
now we create
a base url see how nicely it
auto completes and guidance zero
create two and we've created three
comments
perfect but i don't i don't like this
but why why why are we doing it
necessarily we're not just it is so easy
to do it using promise.all
and do it in parallel
that makes our testing so much faster
and boom oh no what did we miss with the
dream is
there we go if you're asking or the way
you know auto indents and everything i'm
using prettier and the prettier
so it just you know makes it prettier
every time i don't need to indebt myself
this is great
but we can do better because look it's
going through the tenants
and we have the tenants already so let's
do this
uh we math okay and we say
on each tenant
[Music]
add opponent and
this url and
and boom
we're done isn't node.js
wonderful it's so easy to parallelize
stuff
it's it's like magic
okay so now we delete the first thing
how do we delete a tenant
we do we take http comment and we fetch
grades text messages we post
uh a json body but the api
is where is it where is it or is it
with a tenant id okay
ah okay oh
uh but we have the first one we'll use
the first tenant
and we post whatever it doesn't care
what it has in the body so we're posting
like a regular or nothing
and but we don't want to post we want to
delete
so we say method
this deletes the tenant the first init
okay now we list the tenants we can copy
paste that
because we are copy pasting people and
we'll copy paste the expect to
and we expect the list not to equal that
list because we don't know what
order we're getting it so to have
members which members we want the
tenants
from the first from
the second but in in in zero index is
the first
so we take the second and the third as
an
array so we wanted to have members and
because we want
this is this is chi we want the equality
to be deep equality because we're
comparing
objects so we wanted to check out uh the
whole
thing so that's it so we added the
tenants
we deleted the tenants and then we list
the tenants and expect them to be only
these last two so nice
will this work or will the lion eat me
okay npm right i'm doing i'm testing
only this
no it didn't work good the lion hated me
but it just
it's just tickling oh of course
base url okay
let's run it again lion i
fear you not
[Music]
yay the test pass notice the 47
milliseconds
that yes running the docker um
took some time and that's the setup time
but the test itself ran
really really quickly let's still let's
make it run
like 100 times
array 100.
1. so this creates an array and then
we're going over it and we're doing
it but only 100 times let's see how
fast it is we're running the test of
delete
a hundred times that is including
deleting all the rows look how fast that
is that is
crazy fast most of the tests are running
under 40 milliseconds
okay like half of them so
you can run hundreds of tests and have
these tests pass in
seconds so don't be afraid of
integration tests
you don't need to go all the way into
unit that's because you need things to
be fast
integration tests are really fast as
they are
okay and yay we have
just finished but because
okay because i want to be nice i want to
extract the function call it delete
tenant
and that's the base url command
click and now basically around here
but i don't want all the tenants i want
to pass
a specific tenant and take its id
and id and here i want to
pass them into zero
and that's zero oh
i found all of this
okay in unit and everything
okay just a sec
that's good yay all the integration has
passed we'll
talk about in a sec
[Music]
so yes the lion did not eat me
okay so we saw docker composed.yaml we
saw how to set up the db
we saw the apple tools docker compose
mocha feel free it is open source you
can use it get address for service
because we don't know what the postgres
server address is
because we want to make it random every
time we run so we get the address from
docker prepare the database we didn't
see that
not very important reset the database
just deletes all the rows in the table
because i want each test to start fresh
and then set up app
uh and that's nice
because remember that microservice where
we create the app
the nice thing about that if is if we
have a test of another microservice
and it wants to use this microservice it
doesn't need to get it as a docker
container
it can just declare a dependency on it
and just create the app itself make it
listen and that makes the two micro
service testing
really really easy because you can just
require the two
connect the dots boom you have a like
mostly end-to-end test without running
docker at all
okay and we saw how fast it is by
running tests multiple times
perfect
we're on it okay
now why do we need an end-to-end what do
you mean end-to-end it's just one
microservice and the answer is
this is what we call the little
end-to-end test
we've tested the app but we haven't
tested it inside a docker container
and you know we didn't test the run code
and the environment
variables and all that glue code yes we
know that most of it runs
but how do we know that it runs in a
docker container you don't need to run
all of this you can just take one of the
integration tests
and see if it works in the docker
container okay
um no not this one sorry we'll use this
one
okay so we'll do uh the add test it's
the simplest
and it can test whether we test first of
all we need to run
we need to build the docker
our docker container so the docker
container is built
and now look at the docker compose the
end-to-end test is using
it's running postgres but it's also
running our app itself see
this is the the name of the image that
we've just created
guild tires microservices are made for
testing and it's sending the
in the the docker the postgres
connection string
as an environment variable okay so that
when
the docker container runs this code we
get the environment variable
and the app gets the connection string
perfect
okay
okay now what do we need to do here one
add a tenant
list tenants
check that the tenant is there
perfect but we have this we have those
but they're in they're here
our no they're here in the integration
tests
so what do we do look they're perfect
they get a base url and everything
so what do we do we visual studio code
refactor it
and move it to a new file
[Music]
it creates a new file which is really
cool
there we go it didn't oh it didn't work
let's do it again
[Music]
it worked on my machine okay you create
we
moved to a new file this time it worked
[Music]
here it is it's called delete pen that's
really bad we'll call it tenant
ops
and look what it did and if you require
that i don't need that's fine
uh but it imported whatever i wanted to
import and it copied
everything i need here and it added an
import
here this is amazing i need to
add a dot js because in node.js modules
i have to add the
and the the extension uh and then i move
it to commons because i want it also an
end to end
and it you know rewrites everything but
it rewrites it badly because node.js oh
no
it worked perfect uh okay
and now i can do the end to end i will
import
no time i will import
[Music]
from
[Music]
here's my regular tent there we go
[Music]
perfect oh i need your idea there we go
[Music]
okay now we list hands again
i don't know what the visual is just a
second list
it's url and i get
and then we expect tenants
to equal exactly
an area with one ah well what's this
cost doing here perfect
now we need the base r okay first of all
remember the app is running in docker
compose so i need to ask docker compose
for that
so i use pct okay
and another and i use
a weight
[Music]
[Music]
um
get address for service for source
and it needs the end name from the
docker compose tool
and the compose path and the name in the
docker compose that's amp
and the port it exposes so now i get the
app
address that's just the the ip
and the port the base url
is http
[Music]
and we have a test
we have a gun and we got the base url we
add a tenant we list
it and we check that it's the correct
one
and let's it's dot only so we can test
only that
uh and npm ranger smoker lion lion
where are you
yes it passed by the way is it passing
let's
change something okay so that it fails
by the way every test i run when it
passes the first time
i check i make it fail just to see that
it's not passing always
okay perfect it failed as it should
uh now we can run all the tests
[Music]
and boom it's running all it tests oh
no oh prettier
i will in the test i'm also checking the
prettier is okay
i do this run it again
[Music]
and running all of them
will all the tests pass will all the
tests pass
[Music]
there we go yes
[Music]
yes so and we we built the docker image
we showed the dockerfile
previously we talked about the docker
compose oh
nevermind and npm test oh we're using
actually we're not using mocha parallel
tests anymore anyway okay
testing strategy we've seen how the live
code we've seen that it's
not actually very difficult if you have
the correct pieces of the puzzle
which are docker compose or docker to
run
the services like postgres if we
separate
you know the the taking of the
configuration from the run from the
creating of the app and the listening
and then you just http and check http
and check http
is that simple well unless microservice
is a difficult one to test like
lots of cues and lots of things but
that's okay that's not accidental
complexity
that is a real complexity and there's
nothing we can do
but in terms of accidental complexity
there's not
a lot okay and why is this different
from monolith testing from testing a
huge app with like
hundreds of thousands of lines of code
and the answer is because a microservice
is small
integration tests do a great job okay
they run fast they're easy to do there's
not a lot
so no really need for a lot of unit
tests okay
you don't need to mock everything and do
lots of unit tests
because your integration tests are very
quick very easy to write
code is simple not a lot of data set up
and if the test fails it's usually
fairly easy to see why
if you're doing a monolith and you're
doing integration tests we're checking a
lot of the application together
it's very difficult to test very
difficult to set up
and very difficult to see where the bug
is when the test fails
but in microservices because they're
very small
everything is perfect what about unit
tests
just throw all of them away no no no no
no no unit tests are wonderful
and use them for mostly pure logic like
you know functions that you know
input algorithm output use them for that
uh this sql roll to thing is is perfect
it's great for those
many permutations where you have a lot a
lot of permutations you don't want to
check them all in integration tests
so you take that logic you tease out the
logic
make it into a unit that is easily
testable and test it as a unit test
just don't do the test all units any
function i write i write it as a unit i
write a unit test for that you don't
need that integration tests are what is
therefore
use the unit testing to test what are
really testable units
things that are mostly independent as
units
and make sense to test and how do i
ensure i write this
well we have a very easy at apple tools
quality is very important how do i
ensure that me and my team write tests
and the answer is very easily never run
the microservice locally
if you write code you want to tell you
want to check that the code you write is
round
you can't run the microservice and use
postman to http things and check that it
works
you are not allowed to do that okay
that's rule number one
never run your microservice locally so
how do you check that your
code works easy you write a test so
everything you write if you really want
to check that it works
you write a test and those tests remain
forever
and that is how we make sure that we
write tests for our micro services
and it's a pretty good way you don't
want to write tests you want to deploy
straight to production
fine by us but it's on you uh
and it never happens okay uh okay what
is the right mixture of unit
integration into and there are a lot of
schools there's the pyramid school which
is a lot of unit tests
this is true for monolith apps i think
for microservices this is less true as
we talked about
so not a lot of unit tests only make
sense a lot of integration tests like
we've seen they're really fast and very
easy to write
and very very few end-to-end small
implements
the right mixture is as we said a lot of
integrations
but if you can do a unit tease out unit
code that can be tested separately
without a lot of mods so with zero month
do that an end-to-end small implemented
test just a microservice as a docker
container
just to make sure that the docker image
works right one or two
and and there are scenarios that can't
be integration testing
some really weird ones we have those
that happen to
do an intellect and don't forget to
write a big end-to-end that tests
all the microservices together but that
is the subject of a really separate talk
business it's a whole separate subject
how do we do that
or do we need it at all
what about you know a lot of people
write microservices as controller
calls to service calls to a dal you know
a data access layer or it's called a
store or repository in some places
i'm not a huge fan because microservices
are small i don't need all those layers
so sometimes you do okay i have some
where the store the data access is very
hairy
so i i have those and what i
do is i test the store separately as a
separate thing
because it's complex logic this is a
good example of not testing
the whole integration test not testing
the whole micro service
not only the old microservice but the
store separately
so i'm not sure you can hear that i'm
pretty sure you can
but if you can this is the original song
these boots were made for walking and
that's just what they'll do
one of these days these boots
and microservices remember made for
testing and that's what you should do
because one of these days these tests
are going to help
a lot for you and i always always always
finish testing uh talks i don't have
just testing talks but if it's a testing
talk
i always finish with the litany of fear
by frank herbert's june
usually i make everybody go you know
stand up and
recite it with me in this case
tough so i will recite it myself so
please listen
i must not fear fear is the mind killer
fear is the little death that brings
total obliteration
i will test my microservices i will
permit them to pass over and through me
and when they have gone past i will turn
the inner eye to see their path
where the fear has gone there will be
nothing
only my tests will remain
thank you very much
[Music]
okay uh questions this is questions time
yes thank you very much jill for the
presentation it was really
impressive thank you i can see that
there are no
questions right now in the chat
but if anyone has any questions or
anything comes to your mind
uh just feel free to join this lecture
while i was mentioning before
uh we all are available there so
you can talk to jill there as well
it is already on the screen you can see
the link there
uh so feel free to join it and we will
be
also mentioning their our next meetups
uh so you will stay tuned and also we
will be sending their feedback from so
um post questions on slack or
uh if you have any questions just feel
free to type it into the chat and we can
go through it right now
i can see a question there in the chat
so uh i'm just answering ante tomic
yeah and i will just finish so that
there will be a feedback form
uh posted into selection so if you can
fill it in it will be great
uh and we will now wait for andy if he
has any question
right now or if he continues in the uh
in the discussion on slack
so feel free if anyone has any other
questions
just type them in and jill can answer
them i believe
yep i'm here
yeah no questions coming right now
i'll be in the slack channel for another
day yeah i think that we can
end it here right now uh
so thank you very much you once again
for this awesome presentation it was
really pleasure to have you here and
thanks everyone for joining once again
and
see you hopefully soon bye